one of the the key points major uh that
i want to linger on with drika duncan
who's in philadelphia for us
is the state of pennsylvania they are
still counting votes there there are
hundreds of thousands
still to go and what everyone wants to
know jerica good morning to you is
when will those numbers finally come in
good morning i wish i had a crystal ball
to give you a clear answer but
unfortunately i don't
election officials are not giving a
specific timeline this is what's making
all of this very hard
but we do know that there are roughly
706
000 mail-in ballots that have not been
counted yet and as we've been reporting
here
in front of the pennsylvania convention
center inside you have over 100
election workers that are hard at work
counting those mail and ballots we know
that about 166 000 of those mail-in
ballots still needed to be counted
when you combine philadelphia and
pittsburgh two very big cities here
in the state of pennsylvania while there
have not been any irregularities or
major problems reported
the trump campaign is demanding better
access to locations where ballots are
being processed
and counted the president saying that he
would challenge the results if he loses
here
in pennsylvania but the pennsylvania
attorney general saying that there
is transparency observers from both
parties are already
already monitoring the process
and you know when you think about
pennsylvania why this is such an
interesting state to watch not just
because it is a potential pathway for
the president
but some from 1988 to 2016 it was blue
until the president turned it red again
in 2016. and interesting to note gail
this morning i woke up watching the
local news coverage
it's not the campaign ads we're seeing
but literally ads
telling people to let the election
workers count
yeah jerica anthony i were just saying
that look how hard these people are
working
to know everybody wants to get this
right everybody does thank you jerica
very much thanks a lot